welcome to the gridiron heights
Thanksgiving Day Parade great to be here
first up Philadelphia Eagles riding an
easy schedule to first place and here
come the Rams of Los Angeles look at
their one fan what a cute kid pretty
sure that's their coach Tony and here's
the bells off to a promising start okay
al I've seen this before you'll notice
by the buffaloes expression the bills
are gonna get shaky start going up and
down and then fully implode Romo you
called it again welcome back the
Patriots are cleaning up the AFC East
again and here's the Titans with Marcus
Mariota and Eric Decker or maybe move
out there takers of the Titans and
there's Phillip Rivers I don't think he
knows he's in a parade al was a freakin
LA traffic Gustin here comes the Packers
flow but we're just gonna show you an
and Rogers watching the Packers flow sad
but still interested in his teammates
great board oh no Tony the balloon hit
its head it's heading in for evaluation
oh good he's cleared I mean you gotta
let the balloons play and here comes the
49ers in a celebration of their one win